first of all happy belated birthday
thank you
everything is so different now we can't
do the things that we normally like to
do
what did you have planned and what what
did you wind up doing
because i imagine it was different well
yes i um
i intended i turned 21 last year and i
intended to go to las vegas for my 21st
birthday but my birthday was right when
everything started kind of happening
so i didn't go to vegas once as a 21
year old and i feel kind of like
failed i was that that's like the main
thing you're supposed to do when you're
21.
i am 22 now and hopefully this year i
will be able to go
um but i am definitely a little bummed
that i didn't get to make it to vegas as
a 21 year old at all
you're now wanting like you're in that
rare group of where you've you've had to
do things
twice now during lockdown yeah
it's it's it's wild i i um
yeah my birthday my birthday last year i
was able to still
you know do a big party and because it
was right before everything and then
literally within two weeks that's kind
of when lockdown began
and then this year you know we we are
where we are it was only what like
two weeks ago my birthday so i just um
drove up to
lake tahoe which is like a six hour
drive from la and
went skiing with like three of my
closest friends and
that was it and it was definitely like
the smallest birthday i'd ever done but
it was honestly really relaxing and nice
and so um i just
kind of took it as a as it was
now that the album is out and it sort of
belongs to the people it belongs to the
fans
um has your relationship with it changed
do you hear it differently now
now that you hear feedback from fans i
think a little bit yeah
in certain songs and in certain ways i
think um even some interpretations that
i've heard people have made for certain
songs i'm like it's really interesting i
never
thought about it like that and um a lot
of people have told me that you know
certain songs have really helped them
and touched them and
um that means the world to me so i
definitely think my relationship with it
has
potentially bettered because i uh
finished this album and it was ready to
launch over a year ago so um
i was a bit i don't want to say fed up
with it but i was kind of just like i
you know this music's old it's not it's
not brand new there's
only a few songs that were made within
the last year so i
definitely was at a point where i was
like this needs to just come out
so this chapter can be closed and i can
move on and
um yeah i'm really i'm really happy that
that it is out and that we finally got
it released
so now that it is out and these songs
that you were sort of sick of a little
bit um they're going to be in your life
now for a long time
right um what's what are your what are
your feelings towards that i mean
everything is just so brand new to
everybody else even though it's been in
your life for a long time
are you still excited can you get
excited the way you were when you
when you first laid them down no i think
definitely i can i
um you know there's like certain songs
uh like my song blue
was one of the earliest songs that was
made and that's the most streamed song
thus far off of the album that wasn't a
single so
um yeah i think it's it's pretty it's
pretty awesome and it's been
a very enlightening experience to see
how you know things that i was kind of
like i don't even know if i want from
the album anymore are the
ones that are the most streaming and the
ones that people are connecting with the
most and so
i'm um very excited um to yeah to have
to have it out
um you've been in this business for a
while now
and when you do sit down to
create what do you do you think in terms
of
creating your own space or do you think
in terms of
fighting for space that you see already
exists
because i imagine it's two different
things i think i'm
at this point fighting for my own space
i really want to um you know just have a
sound that is
particularly just me and that when you
know somebody hears a song they're like
oh that sounds like it could be a
madison beer song
that's the goal um and i also just wanna
yeah
i hope to continue to discuss topics
that maybe aren't as discussed or
you know things that i feel like aren't
spoken about in music enough
and i um hope to continue to do that and
this album has shown me that people are
receptive to it
and um they they want it and they enjoy
it so it's been it's been pretty
affirming for me
um privacy as we know especially when
you're young and
and and famous with social media and
everything that you guys have to do
um privacy is is a is a sort of it's a
it's at a premium it's few and far
between so when it comes to putting
yourself
in your songs do you have a line that
you won't cross
are there parts of you that you still
won't put on a record
i think so yeah i think that i've had to
try it and find a healthy balance
between
opening up um particularly about like
mental health struggles or breakups and
things that i've gone through that i i
do find to be personal and private and
things that i don't think
the public necessarily needs to know too
much in depth about
but there's a fine line between you know
keeping my privacy and also wanting to
be a voice for
you know the voiceless and wanting to be
somebody who
talks about mental health when i feel
like it's so stigmatized and i feel like
there's not really many songs that
express
you know how it feels to go through
certain things and i wanted
i wanted my album to showcase some of
that and i wanted to speak on a lot of
that and i
feel um a really
i feel i feel like i've been kind of
like
teeter-tottering with the you know idea
that's like
part of me is so eager and excited to
talk about certain things and i really
want to be the one who
discusses topics that still might be raw
and emotional for me but they're also
so important and i feel like even if i'm
kind of putting myself on that chopping
block where i might be
ridiculed or i might be um you know the
butt of people's jokes or whatever it
might be
i i feel like i i still am inspiring
hopefully and um reaching people who
might need it and i've had such an
overwhelming response of people being
like
you know your music has given me courage
it's made me feel less alone i feel like
i you know i'm not
going through my struggles by myself
because you have talked about yours and
your experiences
and that that makes it very much so
worth it but there is definitely still
things that i'm like
if i'm not at a place where i'm
comfortable talking about things i'm not
going to you know i still respect myself
and my boundaries enough to
not air things out that i'm not ready to
when you do get that feedback from fans
where they feel not
alone and they feel heard and you can
sort of you know provide that voice for
them
i imagine it's an incredible feeling to
hear that
what your music does for them but what
does that feedback do for you
it does so much for me i mean like i
i for a really long time felt very alone
and i felt very
misunderstood and you know like i was
struggling by myself and i think
especially in the age of social media
where things can be
you know picture perfect all the time
and we're all guilty of it
i i think that i wanted
to hopefully i had a kind of myself in
mind when i was
creating it and i was um writing certain
things i was like what would i have
needed in my
you know darkest times to hear and what
would i have wanted to hear from
somebody who i looked up to musically
and i wanted to make something that you
know hopefully
you know me a few years ago would have
listened to and been you know touched by
and would have been helped by so
um yeah i think that that i definitely
had that in mind and i wanted to
i want i wanted to help people as much
as i could and
um it's it's an honor to hear
that it's doing that for them because i
was it was
it's intimidating to be vulnerable
online you know especially in this day
and age when everything is kind of
picked apart and criticized and
um someone like me who receives a
massive amount of hate on a daily basis
it's it's
it's a bit terrifying to open up about
such personal and vulnerable topics
um because they can be used against you
and they can be critiqued and
you know nitpicked and i wasn't sure i
was ready for that but
i like i said if i if i have to kind of
be on the chopping block
in order to make one person feel less
alone i i will do that
i was watching your performance on
kimmel and surrounding yourself with
other young talented women
seems to be a thing um how did that band
come together because you guys looked
dynamite you sounded incredible
but what's it like to have that sort of
that thing with uh what's you and the
girls on stage
thank you we we just recorded ellen a
few days ago as well like i
i'm super stoked to have an all
female band that i've uh that i've
created but yeah we i just wanted to
you know it's kind of interesting
there's this uh i don't know there's
there's multi sides to it i wasn't like
i was seeking out
just girls i wasn't like i needed i need
an all-female
band i wasn't alienating anybody so it
was kind of fair ground and that that
made it even
that much more affirming that like it
was actually three girls that came out
winning at the end that i was like i
want them um so i i'm really
really happy to you know have this
incredible talented band with me that
we've done so many awesome performances
and they have delivered and been
so incredible and i feel like it's also
given so many people you know there's
been
i've seen tweets of a lot of my fans
being like i'm a female drummer
and i don't get you know booked a lot or
i am a female guitarist or a pianist or
whatever it might be and i i feel like i
don't you know compete in the same way
that
men do in that space and you know seeing
that you have a female band has given me
a lot of hope and inspiration and that
that again like fills me with so much
joy because you know i totally believe
that there should be equal playing
grounds obviously and
um that's why i felt it was it was
really important to showcase that on
a stage or on a tv performance show them
that you know
they're you you can do this and you can
you know go on to
achieve your dreams when you need to
not be you for a minute when you need to
not be
somebody who has 20 plus million
instagram followers and
records and television appearances what
is the thing that you do
that is just so detached from all of
that that gives you joy
i mean i i've kind of learned i have
like modes i have kind of like
you know the madison mode that i feel
like i switch on and i go into like
autopilot a bit and i
you know do what i have to do and
whatever but then i kind of and very
easily i could switch it off and just be
myself my friends and my family and the
people close to me will always kind of
trip out if i
do a performance they'll be like how is
this the same girl who's playing like
texas hold'em in the hot tub
that's like out on this stage like
looking like
you know a million bucks and i'm like i
am the same exact person it's just kind
of the switch i'm able to turn on and
off and
um yeah my friends are always like it's
so weird because you just don't it's not
the same it's just completely different
but um
i don't know i just like to try to reset
and try to just do things that make me
feel
grounded i try to stay off of social
media as much as i can
and just be in the moment and enjoy life
while it's here
and uh quickly before i let you go
people are dying to
stand in a crowd close to other people
and watch
you on stage what can you tell fans
what is it going to be like the day that
they are able to
buy a ticket and walk in and see one of
your shows for this what do you got
planned
i think my live stream show was a bit of
like a foreshadowing of what my
real show will be like and i i'm i'm
though the reaction to that was so
overwhelming and it was so positive and
i am so
so excited to get it out
and to um go i want to so bad
touring is one of the i mean like i
think i enjoy performing more than
anything i do so
i miss it terribly i miss my fans
terribly and i i can't wait and i'm very
eager to get back out and see all of
them and hopefully it'll be soon
do you feel that you've gotten maybe a
little bit too used to having all your
things and that maybe only having some
of your things on the road
might become a problem for the first
little while i think so
maybe yeah i might i might not be used
to it for sure but i love it i love poor
life i'm good with my
little like bunk and my cubby i'm happy